[Music]
[Applause]
David Pollock the former Georgia
All-American NFL player and of course
worked with the mothership with college
game day for such a long period of time
let me start with the headlines here
what's your reaction to the ACC they're
bringing in Stanford Cal and SMU
well you better keep up with the Joneses
I mean it's got to happen right like you
see the Big Ten making moves you've seen
the SEC obviously next year bringing in
Texas and Oklahoma I mean the ACC has to
do something and when you look at their
contract they signed a long-term
contract with TV and it was a bad one
like we can go to any business deal you
want to go to Dan like we know it was a
bad deal and they're not making near the
money there's a lot of people in that
League that have been wanting out for a
while and trying to find a way out so
um the league isn't set up in a great
spot if they could bring in some more
juice obviously it might help maybe you
can do something with your TV deal but
the deal that the ACC has with
television is one of the worst in sports
yeah I just don't understand it you can
add but that doesn't mean you know
sometimes less is more as opposed to
this time is more seems less
well and just like with the with the SEC
in the Big Ten like if you're gonna
bring in Brands like you're already a
big organization you're already making a
big a big chunk of money so like SEC
like who are the teams that would make
sense for them to bring in in the future
I think there's a couple teams you're
gonna see like Virginia to me doesn't
make sense that market makes sense but
Virginia Tech fits in the SEC like that
makes a lot of sense they're fans the
way they are that that area would be
perfect NC State versus North Carolina
like that makes a lot of sense again are
we gaining a market and I think that's
what you got to gain a market so you can
gain money and make the television go up
well that's where I don't know if
they're going to be doing that
um but I do know that right now
everybody's going how the heck do I
survive because the Big Ten in the SEC
they're the power Brokers they're
controlling this whole thing they're
going to be okay how do I make sure I'm
okay more likely to leave the ACC
Florida State or Clemson
oh I would say Florida State
I think Florida state would be if I'm
the Big Ten like that's a market I would
want to go down into and get man I gotta
get Florida like I think that would be a
huge coup for the Big Ten I think that
would make a lot of sense I think that's
something that we might see in the
future this is uh the last year where
the current playoff system how is that
going to change philosophies when it
comes to scheduling that you can have a
couple of losses and probably still
squeak into a 12-team playoff or does it
change anything
well I think everybody who wants more
parody Dan I don't know that this
changes that because we're all going to
be looking at the same teams in the end
anyways like last year we could have we
could have written it up any way you
wanted to you probably were going to get
to the similar outcome regardless you're
still going to see the the power teams
in there but I think the home field
thing is going to be dope like I think
it's going to be cool to see home field
advantage for a college football game
that will be really really cool I don't
I think it what it will do which will be
cool Dan is late in the season more
teams are in the mix less predictability
like a lot at the end you're gonna go
you're going to watch these championship
games you're gonna oh man like they
could be they could sneak in and be the
12th seed like teams that get hot at the
end of the season you know they could be
a viable threat maybe now to the college
football playoff as opposed to to what
we've seen in the past so I think listen
we did it because of money we know that
like more money more viewers
um you know by expanding it but I think
more teams being in the mix more teams
getting in the playoffs playoff home
games I think all that would be good for
college football but I I we sort of know
what college football is every year it's
the most predictable sport we have of
all the major sports it's always going
to be you know two SEC schools are going
to be in there you may have Ohio State
or Michigan uh throw in maybe Notre Dame
or Clemson nobody has a problem with the
predictability of college football
do they no I mean I don't you don't
um some people think that here's the
thing though I think a lot of fan bases
Dan would be like heck yeah we're in
this thing at least at least we have a
chance like a lot of people aren't
giving a seat at the table year after
year Cincinnati is the only team from a
non-power you know five that got in that
got anything like how many teams are
going like I'd love to just see my team
get a chance is it going to disprove any
any Miss probably not but at least
you'll have a seat at the table for some
of these teams that in a final four
scenario would never had a seat at the
table we're talking to David Pollock he
was a three-time All-American in Georgia
former ESPN college football analyst has
that sunk in yet
yeah oh yeah football season football
season being here Dan
um you know I'm coaching High School
football which is so cool man and the
football's in the air and it's just fun
to have football back but no it's
definitely a change of pace for me a
change of Lifestyle I'm sure you can
relate like just going from being so
busy and traveling you know so much to
now like last night I'm watching the
Florida Utah game I'm like I ain't got
nowhere to be I I wish I could turn off
the lens of how to watch a game and I
would love to be a fan and just like
walk but I'm like no no like golly like
what does this mean for Billy Napier's
Reign like what does this mean for
Florida like if you switched if you
switch coaching staffs this game would
be this game would be totally different
like that you know Utah's maybe not as
talented as Florida but look how well
coached Utah is and how I mean they know
exactly who they are what they are so my
brain still works that way but football
season is definitely going to be a
little bit different yeah college game
day lost a big member there with you
because you brought energy there and uh
you know it'll be it's gonna be tough
you know every fall you get that feeling
of and you did this as a player where
your body tells you it's time to play
football your body's going to tell you
you know it's time to do college game
day it's time to get on the road it's
time to do what you would do for you
know five or six months out of the year
well and that's why I started I started
coaching High School football last year
and because I really I got to get in
kids lives like I got to really make a
difference I loved what I did on camera
but that was I'm just talking you know I
don't have a lot of interaction and so
getting in these kids lives and now
coaching them and coaching the defensive
line and like like I'll ride the bus
tonight Dan to South Forsyth from North
Oconee like it's gonna there's no it's
not gonna be a glamorous like show for
show for a ride but it's gonna be
awesome like they gave me a headset
which was so cool I was on the like we
had our first game two weeks ago against
the Rival there was a seventh team in
the state and uh North Oconee that power
T took care of business uh but they gave
me a headset and it was just so cool now
to get in the world of oh this is what
you're thinking this is how you're
thinking ahead this is how you're doing
this and
um so football when football when I
broke my neck football got taken away
but it came back in a different form
football will never leave my life like
it has been one of the biggest blessings
and best things that ever came into my
life and it will stay in my life
how did Georgia your alma mater pass
Alabama
I think Georgia Kirby learned a couple
things a few years ago Kirby's always
been disciplined he's always been tough
he's always been able to recruit like
that dude you you listen to Kirby I
think he would blow people's minds if
you listen to Kirby in a room of
recruits and how that dude can work a
room and and get the pulse and knows how
to relate to mamas and daddies and
little girls everything but the biggest
thing Kirby Learned was he had all that
stuff already
he learned how to get players to now
love each other he learned he learned
one plus one is three like he learned
that taking them away from football and
building this and building you know
camaraderie and love of teammate like he
really learned that I think that was the
biggest differentiator between him being
a really really good coach and now being
a great coach on his way to being an
all-time great coach was that it's more
than just discipline hard work toughness
we've got to be together in a team and
we've got to love each other and fight
for one another if I gave you Caleb
Williams or the field for the Heisman
the field easily like that's not even a
debate for me
um here's the thing Dan you know how
this goes with voters and all these
different people that vote there's a lot
of votes out there they don't want to do
a two-time winner again like that's a
part of the formula that's going to be
into it you got to be in the in the
national championship landscape again
USC's defense are they going to keep a
minute they have it in the path I don't
think it's probably I think it's gonna
be more of the same this year he'll be
exciting he'll be dynamic he'll be at
the top of the draft board but I'll take
the field and I'll tell you what one guy
off the radar I think Carson back from
Georgia his odds are through like I
think it's like plus 1300 like go put
some go put some scratch down on that
like because they're going to be in the
national championship picture he's going
to play at a high level he's got Brock
Bowers and a bunch of skill players
around him he's going to win a ton of
football games he looks like he could be
a superstar and he's a guy that I think
might be in New York great to talk to
you again if you need an outlet any
fried day let us know you got things on
your mind you want to talk college
football we'd love to have you
absolutely appreciate that Dan thank you
buddy
David Pollock